welcome to the morning session thanks
for coming um we have avi from is and
he's going to tell us about fitness
symmetries
and computational problems
all right let me turn this on
interesting experience to talk with this
uh whatever she is
let's see
okay so this part of
you know two talks uh
after
mine michael walter will talk at
whatever 11.
and
this is algebraic power supposedly the
algebraic methods part of the workshop
so there will be
mainly analysis and uh
geometry so far and uh there'll be some
algebra and i'll tell you about
connection but actually there's
plenty of math interconnected in this uh
in this story and i'll try to uh
uh describe this project that's been
going on for like uh
uh five or six years with this uh
group of people um
uh as it evolves more or less because
that's the simplest and i think the
nicest way to tell the story and how we
uh learn about it so
the plan is basically to to tell you
about the one problem we want to solve
this singularize your symbolic matrices
that's all defined
uh and one algorithm with you i'm sure
you all know this alternate minimization
algorithm but applied in this case
and then uh
there'll be these loops that uh parsley
you'll see in this talk and then the
next where we internalize what happened
and generalize both algorithms problems
and tools
uh to get more applications and better
algorithms
and
at the end
this is
where we are now is uh
we have a i think a pretty good
understanding of what this
set of techniques and algorithms give
and in particular this was discussed on
the first day
they give a class of
problems for which
you can apply geodesic convex
optimization
and
you can analyze it
really completely and get polynomial
time bounds so you'll see how these
arise and what the algebraic tools that
are
uh involved in getting them
um
that that will be the end of the second
talk i guess
uh what i really you know sort of
love and
also amazed by
in this project is how it touches so
many areas of so many
mathematics physics and
[Music]
computer science optimization so you see
a list that i probably will not go
through
uh of various connections and
applications some of them will come out
later i just want to highlight that this
is
the place i'm coming for my
new complexity theory i'm interested in
in
proving lower bounds i'm interested in
the randomization and
this is how i got to this so totally
inadvertently into
uh you know uh
and the main tools that you'll see that
i want to highlight uh coming from in
variance field so we'll talk about
symmetries and
uh these problems mentioned there uh at
least i'll give you like a slight crash
course on
uh
this part and you'll see again more on
the second
and uh
yeah it gives algorithms and
i'm not sure how far we'll get but
there are these new algorithms that turn
out to be able to solve things that are
you know sort of surprising partly uh
solving certain families of quadratic uh
systems of equations that in general are
hard and
solving exponentially large linear
programs
these are the moment polygons that
you'll see in the second talk
so let me start
i want to describe the problem and the
algorithm so
uh
this algebraic problem i'll start from a
simpler my baby case problem which you
all know and so it's really easy the
baby case problem is just by part i've
mentioned
we have a graph you know
uh
this is uh what uh
you know my kids uh preferences with
candies and the
question is whether i can uh mess them
up in this particular graph it's
impossible
so it is possible
and in this one it is impossible so some
girls have a perfect matching some don't
and the first algebraic connection is uh
is that we can represent the graph as a
matrix so
uh that's obvious that's uh
yeah maybe i should
mention this this is a much older
problem that at least i knew a
polynomial time algorithm for this
problem is ancient it's uh
uh jacobi already
found one
because he was interested in some
systems of ordinary
uh differential equations he really
needed to solve them i mean that's why
the mathematicians in general discovered
algorithms lost because
a long time before you know computer
science existed
um anyway we can represent a a graph by
a matrix let's say the graph g we have
the adjacency matrix of g right and
there one for an edge zero for a known
edge and in this
presentation the
way to say
you know whether matching exists or not
or in fact how many matchings exist is
to write down
the permanent of the matrix the
permanent of the matrix is just
like the determinant without the sign so
we basically add up
over all diagonals the products of
elements in the diagonal so each
diagonal
would correspond to potential matching
that's a very simple formulation the
graph has a perfect matching if and only
if the permanent is positive
but as you probably know and i'll
mention again the permanent unlikely
determinant is supposedly a very hard to
compute function so maybe that's not the
best formulation of the problem
but
edmund suggested the different
formulation algebraic formulation that
will be you know our starting point
uh
you can replace the ones in the
adjacency matrix by variables distinct
variables for every entry
please by the way please stop and ask
any questions if anything is unclear
right i mean i i know it's a very
you know
collection of people with varied
backgrounds and if anything is the
notation or otherwise it's unclear just
stopping
um so we in the adjacency matrix we put
variables
uh so we get another matrix it's now a
symbolic matrix right a g of x of these
variables x and now we can rephrase
uh that once did the perfect matching
problem there is a perfect matching if
and only if this determinant of this
symbolic matrix
is
not identically zero
okay
this should be obvious why i mean this
determinant is a polynomial you can
expand it
and
the what the non-zero monomials will
correspond to
products of variables along diagonals
generally the diagonals of this matrix
so they're long matching
and the only thing you need to notice is
that no
determinant of course is signs plus and
minus but no monomial can cancel another
because all the variables are this
okay so that's another uh formulation of
perfect matching it's in p because
perfect matching is in p
but the
beauty of the of edmonds insight was
that he looked at this problem and then
suggested the generalization very
natural generalization
here we are interested in determinants
of this type of matrices but he said
well let's
not put just distinct variables in a
matrix let's just put an arbitrary
linear form in every
uh angle of the matrix
and uh so right so
we make sure such
does this work
yeah it's a linear form in it
so one way to represent such a symbolic
matrix is just
as is written here you have a bunch of
matrices in the field a1 a2 up to am
and you write the uh
sum of a i x i when the x i's are
variables so you get such a
matrix
and
again symbolic matrix and you may be
interested you know
so the singularity problem that everyone
suggested was
i give you such a matrix so i'll give
you this tuple a1 4am and ask you
whether this determinant
is identically zero
okay so that's the problem we will care
about we really care about this problem
uh and i'll explain why and uh now it's
not obvious that this is a polynomial
time algorithm it's more general than
before when now things may cancel and so
on
so
what do we know
we asked whether there is a polynomial
time algorithm more than 50 years ago
and we still don't know
it's a nice problem why should we care
well another by the way
observation uh really
was made long ago when randomized
algorithms became involved
is that this is a really easy problem to
solve if you allow randomization and the
algorithm is really simple i mean it's a
symbolic
matrix you cannot expand it because
there's exponentially many terms but if
you plug random values to the
variables
big enough range then it's very easy to
see that uh
the chance you will hit a
uh your hits at zero so if if if the
symbolic determinant is identically zero
whatever you plug in you'll get zero but
if it's not the chance you'll land on
the zero is negligible so it's a really
good probabilistic algorithm so we just
care about the randomization here
removing the randomness if we want to
put it in p
why is it why is this problem so
essential why is it not just another
algebraic problem that maybe doesn't
talk to yourself
uh for several reasons valiant uh in his
theory of algebraic complexity uh
discovered this that this problem really
captures all algebraic identities i mean
if you ever wonder why you see so many
uh symbolic determinants all over
mathematics uh
they capture formulas basically and the
any algebraic identity you know can be
formulated as a question of whether
symbolic determinant is zero there are
plenty of them
that's one reason so it's a complete
problem in a sense in fact it's a
complete problem for a class that we
defined
there are many special cases that i
arrive in combinatorics and in algebra
and so on which fit into this
framework but the
perhaps most amazing
reason for the importance of this
problem
is the following implications suppose we
found the deterministic polynomial time
algorithm for this problem
then you see the implications there
something in brackets be different than
empty
and for those who never saw this kind of
uh you know uh
implication it's stunning in several
ways so it's uh first of all you know we
have uh
have a way of proving well what is this
brackets around the
pdf and mp is just the algebraic version
this is the algebraic classes that
valiant defined
vp and vnp
and separating them is you know
where we stand is just as hard as
separating p for men people
and what this statement that cabanette
imperiates in parieta showed about 20
years ago is that
if you have an algorithm for one problem
this problem
then you pull the lower bound you prove
that another problem is hard in fact the
problem you prove hard is the permanent
the permanent is a complete problem for
the uh class v and p for the analog
piece like an np complete problem in the
algebraic setting so if you find the
algorithm for one problem you prove that
another problem is hard then in fact
solve the major
upper problem in complexity theory so
uh in some talks i mean as you'll see we
are going to get into algorithms for
problems like the singularity which are
basically look like gradient descent so
sort of a nice way to remember this is
quite possible that
gradient descent will be useful for
proving that p is different than np it's
also pretty mind-boggling
uh any questions about this i'm not
going to yeah
the first one is there anything to gain
by not using linear forms with like
higher order polynomials in there
no you can reduce higher order linear
forms through
like polynomials into uh
into linear forms uh it you will pay in
the description of the polynomial so if
you have a small algebraic circuits for
these polynomials you can reduce it to
that there is nothing to be gained
and the second question i have is are
there any other examples or
randomization implies that p is not
equal to a number
algorithm can be directed
to the point that if p is not equal to
rp then there is some exponential time
algorithms so this is like a reverse
yeah yes that's a very good question so
in palazzo and i showed
that
if you have a heart problem like you
know satisfiability or
whatever traveling salesman is
exponentially hard and in fact you can
remove
randomization from every
from every probabilistic algorithm and
you are right this is a very good
observation that you made and then it
seems like we are done if we win either
way of course the subtlety isn't exactly
the assumption of what hard means
here uh
okay in the in the
paper within palliative and this how
this versus randomness uh
result what you need is a circuit lower
bound so you need to say that
whatever satisfiability or hamiltonian
cycle or whatever and some np-complete
problem is hard for non-uniform
algorithms for circuits
circuits can simulate randomness easily
so there is no contradiction here what
you demand is a non-uniform assumption
in that result and this is uh you wanted
deterministic
uniform polynomial time algorithm for
singularity but yeah it's a very good
very good point so i mean i still
believe
that one can be randomized this because
of that reason but we cannot use it we
cannot plug it in
uh and as i mentioned that's that's uh
how i came into this uh
uh
looking at this um and looking for
algorithms for singularity
uh okay so now let's talk about we are
not going to solve this problem because
otherwise we'd have that
algebraic piece different valuebike
entries i want to tell you what we saw
so it turns out that symbolic matrices
have a dual life is the same
picture as before
we are given these matrices and we ask
whether this symbolic matrix is singular
uh
in the case you know implicitly i didn't
say it but we sort of all you know think
that variables commute in most of our
daily lives and in this case asking
whether it's uh the determinant of zero
is the same as asking whether this
symbolic matrix is
singular make sure it's so variable as
well in the field of rational functions
over these variables so that's what it
is and we told you
the status of this
the probabilistic algorithm we don't
know the deterministic algorithm but you
can study this and especially if you are
interested in lower bounds that's really
how i i
got into this trying to
understand the non-communicative case
just think of these variables as
non-commuting maybe they represent
matrices or something
and you can ask the same question i mean
is a symbolic matrix like this singular
and now to define this what field you
are working on what is the field of
rational functions of non-community
variables is a complex beast i'm not
going to define it here we'll see other
definitions of the same question later
which are elementary but anyway people
studied this and
it was not even clear it seems like a
much harder problem this non-community
of analogy even just proving that it's
decidable
this is syrian in the communistic case
took a long time
and the best upper bound that was known
was the exponential time probabilistical
deterministic
so what i mainly want to tell you about
is this algorithm with the
gargoyles and oliveira from about five
years ago
giving a polynomial time algorithm for
this problem
and sort of gradient descent type
algorithm for this
over the rationales or the complex
numbers
and soon after it was proved using
different algebraic methods
to the case of
you know basically any field
but i'll tell you only about this
okay
good these are the problems so now i'm
going to turn to algo intensive
okay so the algorithm will employ for
solving uh uh this alternate
minimization which
we'll see so let's uh
go back to our baby problem then perfect
matching and then we'll apply it uh to
this problem and then later to the
problem we want to solve
um
the perfect magic problem and the
there's yet another formulation that's
algebraic uh
that captures perfect matching that will
be key for us and this is a scaling
problem basic scaling problem many of
you must have seen it
what's the scaling problem uh i give you
a non-negative matrix
and i
you know a doubly stochastic matrix of
course is a matrix or all sums and
chromosomes are one
and what i ask you is whether the given
matrix can be scaled to be doubly
stochastic so what is scale
what i allow you is to multiply the rows
and columns by constants
in other words pre and post multiply by
a diagonal matrix so that's what you are
allowed to do and the question is
whether you can make a doubly stochastic
by these operations
uh let me
state it
more
formally but the question you are given
a and you ask whether there are r and c
so that
uh when you pre and post multiply when
you scale you get one column sums
approximately one in other words
for any epsilon you can find r epsilon
and c epsilon so that the all sums and
current sums will be one up to epsilon
and you can do this for every epsilon
then you can we say we you can scale c
this seems like uh you know a you know
fuzzy version to define the scaling
problem but it's the right version if
you care about perfect matching because
you can do this if and only if the
permanent is positive even of the of the
matrix a so it's a zero one matrix if
and only if it has a perfect matching
it's not hard to say show and that's a
good exercise for you
and people looked at it for actually
lots of scaling problems for lots of
reasons in numerical analysis signal
processing
uh
then i'll mention it we look at it for
approximating the permanent
and
yeah it has many motivations and many
algorithms
and different analysis and yeah we'll
see one
okay
so let's say
that's how we are going to solve the
perfect matching problem and that's the
kind of algorithm we later use to solve
the singularity non-commutative
singularized problem
so let's try to do it so we are given a
matrix maybe it's a matrix also a byte i
thought bypass graph and we ask can this
be scaled by one column
operations
it's a sort of
weird question i mean if you think about
it
in the scaling problem the
parameters source of math you are given
like two and three
things to do right the scalars to
multiply the rows and columns and you
have two unconditions
and
yeah it looks like a fair game of course
there's matrices that cannot be scaled
for example the zero matrix cannot be
scaled
so let's see about this one how would
you try to what would be an algorithm to
scale this matrix and uh here comes this
you know algorithm of synchron and
actually people discovered this even in
the 30s there are various things
sometimes without analysis
we want to know whether we can scale it
so
and
of course the roles and column
conditions conflict
so here's a simple naive maybe bold idea
it's just you know you want to solve
uh this big problem let's solve half of
it let's try to see whether we can scale
the
okay because simultaneously maybe it's
up
so let's
just solve it for the words can we scale
the rows
yes no yeah okay of course that's a
trivial problem okay so let's try it so
we can scale the rows okay we scale the
rows the columns don't don't work let's
scale the columns
okay now the rows don't work so let's
scale the rows
and we can continue this
and you will see that it converges so it
doesn't convert i mean it flips between
these two states so this
doesn't convert this particular
algorithm doesn't convert maybe it's
okay because this graph didn't have a
perfect matching so
uh that's good maybe
so we better try it with another example
uh before let me just also formally
state the algorithm it's just a two-line
algorithm right it's a
you know you iterate uh scalable scale
columns this alpha and c of a are just
the obvious way of uh the scaling
coefficients is one over the whole sum
or one over the columns
okay very simple algorithm
um
and this is uh really the alternating
minimization heuristic
we will generalize it later but it just
you you solve part of the problem that's
easy when you have
many constraints and you just separate
them and solve each part separately
uh suppose we look at this matrix which
does have a perfect matching idea of the
anti-diagonalist
or ones
corresponding to this graph
here i scale the words
now i scale the columns
i split the rows and those of you with
the sharp eyes will see that
some of the things and anti-diagonally
increase and the things in those
upper triangles will shrink and actually
that's what it converts us to
in this case
so it converges and this graph does have
a perfect matching so that also looks
good and in fact it's uh it's good
always
so
here's the algorithm and the
uh the main so let me finish with the
algorithm what you do is you
run these iterations some polynomial
number of times like mq
it's just a stupid naive algorithm which
is greedy
after this number of steps you just test
well one side let's say the columns add
up to precisely one and the rows are
within
you test whether they are within one
over n of being one so this epsilon it
takes to be one over n and you just
declare
you know if it is then you say the
permanent is positive otherwise you say
permanent is zero that's what you
that's what the algorithm does
so i claim that it works and it works
efficiently as you can see and there are
many analysis and i want to give you a
particular one that we for completely
different reason did about 20 years ago
the reasons of uh
deterministic approximations of the
permanent with linear and some old
nitsuki and it's really simple and in
fact this analysis will show up again
and again
um
so we are as we scale those scale
columns scalars here chromosomes we are
just creating a sequence of matrices
they are initial a and then a one a two
s
and so on and like ashier i said in the
you know the
first lecture on monday uh
these are you can think of them as
discrete dynamical systems and discrete
dynamical systems how do you analyze
convergence there's
practically
uh one way you find a good progress
measure you find a good or dissipating
measure and
what we did in this paper with to pick
the permanent this function itself to be
a progress measure if you pick it then
things are really simple so there are
three steps to every analysis using a
you know the open of function progress
measure
one is a bound and it's very easy to see
that
the permanent of any of these matrices
is at most one because these are
stochastic by rows or stochastic by
columns permanent is more the product of
four sums or the products of column sum
so it's at most one
so you have a bound
second thing you want to show that every
step of the algorithm you know makes
progress in this progress measure
and i claim that
this role scaling or column scaling if
if there is room to go it will grow by
at least
this factor one plus one over n okay you
are you know that you're still not one
over and close
uh
because that's what you check in the
algorithm here
so
uh it grows and this proof is one line
it's just arithmetic mean geometric mean
inequality so it's really simple
and the third step is also simply this
is a diameter bound right you want to
say you always start not too far from
the solution
and in this case uh
you know if the permanent is positive
which is the case you are interested and
if it's zero it will remain zero forever
uh if it's positive it's not too small
and all we need is something
exponentially small exponential low
bound because
as you go multiplicatively this will
take polynomial number of steps
and this again it's uh it's really
simple you just scale once and then you
you see that you'll have a diagonal with
every entry at least one audience so you
get this
so it's really really simple and we'll
see how to generalize it and what's
needed when we try to generalize it
question so far this uh this is the
algorithm we we are going to use
can you read off the paper for smashing
from the final matrix
yes you can read of a perfect message
from uh
the result a really interesting question
is what do the numbers mean i mean in
this case there was a unique performance
it turns out that the surviving so
some things will go to zero it's easy to
know what they are these are uh
the edges that
participate in no perfect 19
the one there'll be ones
maybe if these will be edges that appear
in every perfect matching
and then there'll be positive numbers
between zero and one
the meaning i don't know i wish i knew
it's really it's very interesting
uh
okay so we see this is easy and this
will change later
uh
you know people don't we don't learn
this in
college this algorithm for perfect
matching even though it's two lines it's
so pretty and so simple to analyze much
simpler i think than the augmented path
anyway uh this thing has analog for
non-uniform scaling sometimes you are
interested in different margin now so
modular problems are are very common you
want all some that column sounds to be
something else
it's like max flow and
there are many scaling problems also
we'll see quantum scaling problems later
anyway i just want to mention that you
can
do the same exactly for the non
uniform scaling with the same algorithm
okay so now i want to move to the real
problem which is this non-commutative
singularity and operator scaling
and here
just a couple of years after this paper
with the
linear samurnitzky govic made what i
call a quantum leap which is at least
at least two meanings so first i want to
say something about quantum
generalization of classical problems and
this is a cartoon
um
in general you go up dimension by one
uh so here we will start with the matrix
scaling we start with the positive
matrix in operator scaling which will be
the quantum generalization you go to a
quantum uh to a positive operator i'll
explain what it is but it's a tuple of
mixes that
you usually go from l1 norm to l2no
it doesn't have to have meaning for you
i'm just
drawing this analogy
you know diagonal matrices or vectors
become
cells that are
invertible and that's how what will be
used to scale
there is a notion of what that you know
tensor like this the type of matrices is
scaled it's a very simple analogy of
the notion of double stochasticity which
will return to
here and uh you know you can do it also
in the non-uniform case so there's a
very simple analogy
and uh
wanted to use this analogy in order to
solve the commutative singularity
problem that's what he was interested in
and here's how he wanted to
look at it so it turns out
our original problem was uh
you know this singularity problem so the
input was the type of matrices which
defined the symbolic matrix and we were
interested in this singularity questions
and he's he pointed out that the couple
of matrices the tensor of course can
represent lots of things in particular
in quantum information theories can
represent a positive operator
what's a positive operator completely
positive operator what defines a general
quantum operation or error operation
sometimes
it acts this operator also again the top
of matrices acts on a matrix p
simply by this sum
some a i p a i transpose of dagger if
they're complex
okay so that's this is it it's a linear
operation on the matrix p and of course
if p is a positive semi-definite matrix
then it remains so
and that's very important quantum
information theory this message p would
be density matrices of you know
represented quantum states that's what
they apply them to
okay so there's another meaning to a
tuple and as i mentioned there's a
notion of when an operator like this is
doubly stochastic which is a complete
analog of you know what it is in the
matrix case so you have these
equations
and
one you know just one way to represent
them is that when you apply this
operator to the identity you get the
identity and when you do the transpose
then you get the identity as well this
is like all
all sums and column cells
so we can ask whether we can or cannot
scale
an operator it's another computational
problem
and
his insight govi's insight was that
the operator scanning problem is that
this
at least if one implication you know you
cannot scale l
implies that l is singular as for
community variables
and unfortunately this was only one
direction and this was not the right
notion and
what we understood what started or one
important in uh you know input to this
work was that
uh it captures exactly the
non-communicative singularity problem so
the scaling question i give you an
operator can be scaled this equivalent
to the non-community singularity problem
that i told you
will solve
the other insight was that since this is
a complete sort of automatic quantum
generalization of
the problem maybe a completely automatic
quantum generalization
from
uh generalization of the algorithm would
work that was
his second insight ago with and he
suggested an algorithm you want to scale
an operator well scale the row scale the
columns in this case rows and columns
you just pre-multiply by a non-singular
matrix on the left on a singular matrix
on the right simultaneously to all of
them to all the top of the ai's you
don't have to rethrew it you just have
to glance at this square
and realize that this is the same
problem it's a alternate minimization
you solve part
the row is part this column part and you
iterate and at the end you test whether
you are close
and you declare it you know non-singular
or singular according to
whether you can get close enough or not
you even suggested the
progress measure
analogous to the permanent in the
classical case this is called the
capacity again you don't have to read
the formula
but it's simple it's just uh
it's not obvious how to compute it but
it's a
simple formula it's the infimum of all
positive different matrices of the ratio
between the input and output of the
the output and input of the of this
operator the points about choosing this
like with a permanent is that it
composes well with this operation
with
operations so
in fact it's it's pretty easy to prove
that it's captured just like with the
permanent perfect matching it perfectly
captures singularity on non-singularity
they just want to know whether the
capacity is positive
and
the analysis
is exactly the same
you know it's very easy to bound the
capacity of you know the sequence again
you have a discrete dynamical system you
are generating a sequence of operators
by this uh you know
scalings
uh
the same arithmetic means your method
mean works
and you see that you grow if you have
room to go by this operation
and that's where we got stuck uh in 2004
how to prove this diameter bound how to
prove that when you start if the
capacity is positive
uh
then
you know it's it's only exponentially
smaller not much smaller
and this is really the key to what's
going to happen now this algebraic
part
that's really what we proved and
[Music]
it was which gives of course the
polynomial time upper bound right if you
start exponentially small this will
converge in polynomial time
is that
the input needed in order to prove this
uh is you know at least as far as i know
uh involves algebra and variance theory
and notions uh that i'll talk about in a
second like degrees of environment
polynomials so through philip's question
in the first day to i think nicolas
about situations where
uh you know why can't you do it why do
you need your this convexity why do you
need group structure can't you bare
hands attack this problem and
i see no way of doing anything like this
for
this problem or problems like this
there's just
no way there's an algebraic theory that
will provide you means for proving such
a diameter bound and i don't see any
other
uh you know
bare hands or you know shields she'll
both fall the droid gets you such a bum
even a finest bar
a concrete final bound i don't know
um
so we have this algorithm it's
polynomial time and actually it solves
not just this problem but lots of
problems so i mentioned it's already in
the beginning
but
and i you already saw two problems which
are described their inputs is just a
couple of matrices right
uh
uh singularity problem and the positive
operator scaling problem in fact i
listed here six different problems and
they all are problems given uh the input
is the top of
matrices and there are problems in in
very different
domains and they are all equivalent
i mean the first five are equivalent the
last is is actually a special case
of the rest and for those of you who
remember suv with stock uh
he mentioned
a work on
on the both complete inequalities these
inequalities with generalized health and
uh
young and all these
other inequalities computing the the
optimal constant in these inequalities
uh it's also part of this so they are
all the same and they all you know
inherit this polynomial time algorithm
okay so uh that's the consequence of
this algorithm tells us that by now more
more is known more problems or not that
are solved by this method
uh
but
okay let me ask if there are questions
and then i want to say something
about the
uh you know environment theory and how
it enters this analysis of this
of this algorithm
so question so far
complexity any relevance to the
determinant versus permanent
yes so the problem we are trying to
solve
uh
if there is a deterministic part so what
is solved here is the non-commutative
version
of the the terminal problem of the
singularity problem
this is not the problem this is not the
result that will imply that permanent is
different than determinant what we want
what we are asking ourselves
continuously and there's
much more life that i will not be able
to talk about is to see whether
algorithms of the same type might be
used for the community singularity
problem and you know them will be home
but what what is limiting them that's uh
for me that's a major motivation so so
far you know this result doesn't resolve
this question but the motivation is
indeed separating permanent from the
terminal
it also connects maybe i introduce this
uh
your question to mention
uh one of the main approaches to uh
separating the determinant and permanent
surprising vp from vmp is
what's called the gcc geometry
complexity theory
of malmady and surrounding
and it's an algebraic geometric approach
but it uh merges very well with the kind
of
you know both the
algorithms and hardness results as well
or barrier results that
you know
we derived so there's a confluence of
this very similarly seemingly different
uh
approaches to the permanent versus
determinant
don't tell you like uh you know five
minutes crash course yeah so just a
quick question i think you mentioned
this algorithm is kind of like gradient
descent light yeah uh could you briefly
comment on like why i will comment on in
uh
i can't say it now i mean
alternate minimization sometimes is
called the fixed step gradient descent
what you do uh in
in gradient descent is you uh go in the
direction of the gradient
in some steps
where you cleverly pick the the side
uh
in the
alternate minimization and let's say the
general framework in a couple of slides
you are
basically going along certain gradients
that you prefer so locally things easy
you go there and you go as much as you
can because you don't lose by that so
you can think of it as a variant of
gradient descent that's why it is and
you'll see more in the second thought
i'll tell you something about the
environment theory i don't know how many
of you uh
know about this
it's an amazing field uh
it is a study of symmetries which is
just group actions on objects and
they're all bits and they're in variants
and let me give you a couple of examples
so you all know this graph isomorphism
problem that's a an obvious problem of
you know you're trying to understand
uh
you know how the symmetry group acts on
the vertices what happens to the graph
uh
yeah you've all seen this uh you know uh
build a table you push the white ball
and then you let the system evolve here
the you know the group acting is time
it's just
uh which is reversible here if
collisions are elastic
so just like below
in other cases some group is moving a
set of objects
and uh here you can take two shapes in
the plane and just cut them with
scissors let's say along straight lines
and rearrange them so there's
some group
acting and
you have all these situations and what
you are trying to understand despite the
fact that there is some underlying
dynamics i mean this group can change
the objects around
what doesn't change these are the
invariants so you want to understand how
things move they move along orbits and
what are the invariants the things that
don't change the quantities that don't
change when you are
applying
group operations to these objects so the
last example i think it's obvious that
the
area
i mean say you don't overlap the pieces
you cut then the area is preserved and
it's a non-trivial there but an
interesting
fact that you know the area is the only
environment
so any two shapes
you know
within our sites
can be moved from one to the other using
these operations in three dimensions
volume is not the only environment
uh here well you learn in physics what
are the invariants the energy and
momentum and they are the only ones
in the case of graph isomorphism
we are far from understanding the
invariancy
the kind of groups we are going to look
at here are linear groups groups of
matrices acting on vector spaces
and these stars mean that there are you
know various qualifications you need to
put in that i will not go into
simplicity
and
it's really interesting how this theory
has you know both an algebraic part and
a geometric part i'll talk just about
the algebraic part and then
micro will talk about the geometric part
so this is a polynomial in variance that
i'll show you and you'll see this
non-communicative duality later
uh here are some basic objects of
invalid theory that i want to highlight
that's the one slide i have on this so
in a case of linear group a group of
matrices arching on a vector space just
by
making multiplication
and
so
we can think of the coordinates as
variables so we have polynomials on this
space and an orbit
is just what the group does to
such a
such a vector okay so just all the
vectors you can reach by applying the
elements from the
matrix you have and since we will work
over algebraically clause field we'll
look at the orbits closure
so one important object is the
environment ring in variance those
objects that don't change or quantities
that don't change and they are always
polynomials in this case so they are all
polynomials
that do not change when you apply
the any group elements i'll give you
examples
if the our group is a symmetric
uh
symmetric group acting on vectors just
permitting coordinates then
well i'm sure you know what are the
environment polynomials they are the
symmetric polynomials all polynomials
which are symmetric are not going to
change if you
permute coordinates
and
if it is uh you take if here the space
is the space of matrices you are acting
on let's say by left and right matrices
that's closer to what we are doing
uh anybody knows want to say what is the
preserved quantity let's say the this
matrix is of determinant one
what what quantity of the matrix that
you act on doesn't change
the terminal
it's just the term so generated by the
determinant you should notice that in
both cases
this polynomial so both the
all symmetric polynomials are generated
by the elementary one so we have just
degree and polynomials generated the
whole ring of invariance and also here
it's of
degree n so are we lucky
what is the degree bound i mean can you
describe the generators finally this was
not obvious hilbert proves this that's
uh one of the most important papers in
uh
in the history of algebra and uh
he proves that there's always a finite
generating set of all environment
polynomials
and it is in this paper where he proves
the new challenge theorem and he proves
the finite basis theorem all these
things that are you know common zone of
committee of algebra
just to prove this result this was very
of course
found many other applications but he
wanted to get this
and you can and should ask the question
what is the what are degree bounds for
this you know
and it's very important for us
uh the last object i want to mention is
let's see how much
okay so i have 10 minutes so
eight minutes
um
right philip
yeah
uh the last objects i want to define for
you know some such group action is the
narcon
uh what's the narcon so we have orbits
of this group you take a vector and you
move it to everywhere you can that's the
orbits and you look at the orbit closure
uh the narrow cone are all points that
they're all bit closure contains zero so
in some sense the group makes them
similar to the
to the origin to zero there are sort of
the the trivial elements in the vector
space according to this group action
uh
in this definition uh the algebraic
definition says it's simply all the
vectors in your space that when you
apply an environment polynomial to them
you get zero
okay they are nullified by all
environment polynomials and it is a
that's an algebraic variety and that's
important
and the
hilbert and manfrotto analytic
equivalence that i just mentioned that
another characterization of this narcon
is that it's all points which are which
look like zero so you can push them as
close to zero as you want and you should
remember the definition of matrix
scaling when you are pushing
the
uh matrix by a group to make it look
like uh
uh to make it uh
scale which is the analog maybe it's not
obvious analogous
and
making is close to zero is the same as
you start seeing an optimization problem
here is
trying to see whether
some group elements can take the norm
of this vector to zero
that's the same
so we have an optimization problem and
this is what we are going to generalize
in a second these are what we saw
special cases
and this connection between analysis and
algebra
just cannot stress are important
uh there are cons in these examples in
the case of any final group it's just a
zero uh the zero vector is the only
vector you can make
zero by permutations and here you know
uh
the narcon turns out to be the singular
matrices just makes sense
the terminal is zero and in general lots
of things you learned in algebra are
null kinds of
you know natural groups important groups
are the narcon of conjugation and you
know there are many other such so
often you never mention any group action
you define these things without
mentioning groups and certainly north
americans but they arise very naturally
from this point of view
so narcon membership so it looks
technical and you know who cares it
turns out and you've seen two examples
already
that
narcon membership when they given a
vector is it in the narcon of the group
action
is a natural problem you are familiar
with
perfect matching is one
and uh this uh non-commutative the
operator of scaling is one and many
others are mentioned in a second
moreover this question is sort of dual
michael will show that to the scaling
problems we discussed so it captures
lots of problems it's just very so in
many problems you don't hear about
symmetry even when you learn in physics
that momentum and
you know energy are
in variance you don't learn you don't
mention
[Music]
environment theory so let me talk about
this uh
generalization last
five minutes uh
so we saw this uh we saw these two
problems basic scanning and operator
scaling and i just stress again we saw
that both were solved with
alternate minimization algorithms
now we see that in both cases now we
think of these matrices that you apply
on both sides diagonal invertible they
are groups right so the group actions
and in fact
you know the algorithm moves along the
orbit of of this group
uh the analysis will get into this in a
second
uh was the clever potential function
which was different in different cases
and we were solving a scaling problem
but
everything and that's the you know main
take home everything the algorithm
naturally lives in an orbit of a group
action
so how do you generalize this a very
simple natural generalization
you look at all alternate minimization
problems and you see when will such an
approach work so i just want to mention
to the question it was asked before
this is one of the most common
heuristics in machine learning and
statistics and so on
you have a complex problem maybe it's
optimization or sampling problem defined
by some function or maybe many variables
and somehow you're lucky and if you fix
all but one variable it becomes easy
and so a natural realistic is to solve
these uh local ones like if you do
sampling using monte carlo uh you know
there is the
um goblin up there sorry
global dynamics uh
what you do like color randomly coloring
a graph you keep recoloring one vertex
fixing everything else
and just iterating so these are all of
this nature there are alternate
minimization with just in most cases we
don't know convergence certainly we
don't know uh
efficient convergence but in the case
we'll consider
which is a group theoretic framework is
uh you know it works so what generalizes
what we've seen before we have a product
of groups acting on a tenzo so you now
apply linear actions in each one of the
dimensions
and
you ask a scaling problem and there is a
natural way to define what when a tensor
is scaled you basically want the
marginal to be uniform
and the general result here is that you
have a
you know what we had before in bigger
generality you can get epsilon
epsilon close to being scaled in
polynomial time in all parameters let me
write it again but i want to stress this
sort of you know why does this greedy
thing works it's a non-convex problem i
mean even the domain is not convex like
the domain is just these groups
so
here it is again i want to say that
again
this scaling problem which is really
dual to testing nalcon membership
is
applicable in many
other problems that i didn't discuss and
let me not discuss them and we have this
uh
this result that convergence efficiency
convergence i want to stress that
polynomial time in one over epsilon is
not enough like in the classical
euclidean case sometimes you want what
you call i guess quadratic convergence
and i like to call exponential
convergence so we want log one over
epsilon there and michael will talk
about this
and i want to stress that
the same analysis works
so
you have this you know lyapunov function
and the
open of function turns out that we
didn't have to be so clever in the
previous algorithms the l2 norm
is a good enough progress measure when
you apply it and and this comes from the
non-communicative duality
uh
yeah there are two easy parts the
bounding
the upper bound and the growth again
afgm works like
magic and this diameter bound
uh becomes harder i mean you just need
to
to use you know more complicated the
basically more complicated the
um environment theory and representation
theory in order to understand this
um
so basic questions i'm you know i have
one more slide like this
to ask at this point you know why does
it work i mean we are in a non-convex
situation
we have a greedy procedure and converges
and you know
always converges to the optimum so you
smell the geodesic complexity here and
you see it's in michael's talk
uh what's going next is scaling and
narcon problems i mentioned this and
you're seeing non-communicative duality
in the next step
and you know all this works if we have
you know our capacity to do alternate
minimization we have you know something
to alternate what do you do if you just
have some group action it doesn't have
this group structure
and michael will talk about this we can
handle this again uh using just the
convexity
so
let's move to the
summary slide yeah what is little vi in
the in the matrix it's like it's a
dynamical system you start from a vector
v
and you start applying the algorithm
generating v1 v2 v3 like we generated
matrices
for for synchron vi is the is the
current matrix it's the current matrix
yes and for operators
yeah
if you look at it it's normal it's
enough as a yeah
yeah so you can in the mesos it will be
the one law but you can represent the
matrix scaling problem initially as the
the little known you know you want to
uh make the l2 rather than every one
norm of the rows and problems one and
then you can use that
yeah
yeah it's uh
so in fact thinker of the original uh
proof
you used there too but he could prove it
only for a
matrix with full support like all the
entries were positive
so just to clarify what you're looking
at is the distance to the marginals
right yes okay yeah but you look at the
distance for the marginal but if you
look at the narcon definition
what you are really looking is how close
to zero can you make you
so you have to subtract off something
which is really the marginals and then
you're trying to push the matrix to zero
okay but but for syncor i mean it's
pretty well known that the right measure
between where you are
there are many measures
yeah but
i mean when you you're doing alternate
projection right so you're actually in
kl so you're actually really inviting
yeah yeah so so here when you say we use
this
that was a choice right that was not it
was a choice the good thing about it is
that this is a universal
choice forget it now basic scaling do
other problems of course you can say i'm
doing projection and try to do it in
care diversity and in fact you are right
but in some cases it even be
better analysis so in some of our papers
we do use
uh scale divergent type measures instead
of l to know
this will affect
quantitative bounds but it doesn't
affect the you know like if you want for
your time
[Music]
that is a good point yeah
uh okay so let me skip to that
i'm going to give the analysis of this
to see what the algebra i could see but
i don't have time
to ask me about it
okay so
just to
mention what you'll see next you'll see
the non-community duality you see the
moment map which extends the gradient
you'll see geodesic convexity coming
and you'll see actually both first of
the second order algorithms so
also algorithms achieving
uh log one over convergence
and
some of the analysis
tools and hopefully you'll get to moment
polytops i hope you will
uh okay so just summarizing i mean
the i mentioned this nothing too much
lister there are lots of interaction
with math that uh
come in it's sort of in fact fascinating
how many areas of mass are
interacting there
the problem i described to you the
singularity problem is an algebraic
problem and nevertheless the algorithm
that works was sort of analytic
and on the other hand this analytic
algorithm sort of dynamic algorithm the
analysis of it or you know a source of
continuous argument the analysis of this
and other algorithms are based on
algebraic tools so it's a sort of tool
uh cool and finally you know symmetry is
uh is you know it
exists in lots of places that maybe you
don't expect them or you don't naturally
think about them and if you have it it's
very powerful
um
yeah so
well these are good questions to ask the
end of the other talk but
let me just
mention that uh yeah the problem i
really care about is this community
singularity and you know solving having
a deterministic polynomial time for it
would be amazing
okay thanks
[Applause]
question
it's at some point that you suggested
that we should think about all these
alternate minimization problems from
somehow great perspective but the
examples that you gave you sort of had
like a
close form solution that would give you
what the group action is once you
actually carry this out did you
encounter some examples where there was
no closed form solution yeah this is
where you could just like absorb yes
there was a group action in the
background yes no so you there are two
questions you are asking
uh you know the example i gave the
uh
it was bad that you will have is that
we'll use uh alternate minimization
because there's a close form solution
for every local thing like in sampling
uh marketing
the cases where you don't the natural
cases where you don't think there are
many and michael will
discuss
are those where
there is no product structure to the
group there could be just some group of
matrices i mean it's not that you can
handle a lot of them but the framework
fits all of them
well it's not clear what to do and
instead of
you know you since you don't have a
platform solution what you do instead
you say ah have a function it will turn
out to be
geodesically convex
and you apply the gradient descent or
second order method to it that's what
you do you don't you will not have a
close form solution you do what you do
in normal convex optimization it will be
a non-convex setting but if you look at
it from the right length it will be
geodesically contract so the intuition
will be the same
the local maximum local maximum minimum
are global ones so just
start pushing yourself towards the
you know you can
there is a natural sense of making
progress without having any close form
solution to a supplement and and and
algebra still enters the picture from
those false yes because the group
you know you have what
understand the group action to
understand the good action you have to
understand irreducible presentations of
the group you have to understand some
geometric
quantities
that are you know implicit in the
description of this irreducible
representation then they control when i
when you say i mean also in the
classical case you say i have
an inner quadratic convergence
it always depends on something on the
smoothness of your function
right
some bounce on the lipschitz uh
continuity or other strong
convexity so you know quantities like
that what is the analog in the in this
very general framework the analog
the quantities that come out of the
geometrical presentation of the of the
of the irreducible representation
i i am not going to define them but they
come up they
you know they relate to smoothness in
the way you think they capture the
smoothness of this
boot action
and this will control the convergence
so in some cases i mean these set of
algorithms have exponential improvement
on
lots of other existing algorithms but in
some of these improvements
they just improve exponentially from a
double exponential algorithm so they
still you know still doesn't get to
polynomial time it just you know it
turns out that is the american type
algorithm so kind of interesting type
algorithms much better than you know
what's classically being used with
typically global basis
yeah so i realized that you know all
these examples are you know not machine
learning type
application
there are some things that come up that
are combinatorial optimization like and
in matching i mentioned like
intersection of two methods can be done
this way but
i don't know i don't have others i mean
uh i'm sure there are i mean there are
some applications to learning
methods and tendril
gaussian models
that is recent and uh
yeah anyway there are some a few others
but i don't you know i i think that
there's huge room of uh
understanding what it can be applied to
for problems that
are out there i'm sure that symmetries
exist in many of them and
can be useful
[Music]
no but it's a very good question and
it's almost an equivalent so it turns
out
that if
permanent
is indeed exponentially harder than
determinant for method circuits then in
the same paper in palliative cabanet
show that
it gives you a deal randomization of
this
you know this symbolic determinant
problem so it's almost an equivalent i
didn't
then that i just told you so the reverse
is pure
the result here or the resulting which i
mentioned in the beginning i cheated a
little bit it seemed it turned out that
if you have a deterministic polynomial
time algorithm for this
civilized problem you either separate
the terminal from permanent or you put
some circuit low bound in the boolean
case so you you you know you put
something amazing either way but you
don't know which
all right
you